(dramatic music)
- There's this house in this
neighborhood in New Jersey
that actually isn't a house.
It's hard to see, because
it's behind this gate,
but if you look at it from above,
you'll see that it's actually
a really large building.
Kind of looks like a warehouse.
It has dozens of air conditioning units
and it's just sitting here among a sea
of ordinary suburban homes.
All of this is just a facade
hiding this massive building
that is a landing station for AT&T,
the place where these
massive undersea cables
that connect the world,
hit the eastern seaboard.
(suspenseful music)
We now know for certain
that the U.S. government
spies on those cables with the
help of companies like AT&T.
And according to a
leaked map from the NSA,
they process all the
data that they collect
somewhere in New Jersey in
a facility called Pinecone.
Lining up these maps points to this
secretive disguised building
as one of the best candidates
for where this surveillance
is being processed.
But there's a lot more
of these hidden buildings
around the country.
Thanks to leaked NSA documents
and some thorough investigative reporting,
we now know some of their locations.
Like the fake house in New Jersey,
these other cable spy facilities blend in
as benign, nondescript buildings
avoiding any undue attention
along the streets of New York
or San Francisco or Dallas.
These few hundred cables
that connect our world
contain an unfathomable amount of data,
all of our communication,
all of our connections,
and it would seem impossible
that any government agency
would be able to spy on it all,
impossible, that is, if
we didn't have solid proof
that they do.
So let me tell you the story of the cables
that connect our planet
and show you that if
you can tap into them,
you can watch the world and they have,
and they've been doing it for a long time.
- [Reporter 1] 320
million records every day.
- [Reporter 2] What
we're talking about here
is a total revolution
of the whole concept of war.
- Collect it all,
exploit it all.
(TV static)
- Now is the moment where I
say thank you to the sponsor
of today's video.
I'm very grateful for sponsors.
I wouldn't be able to do this job
and make independent journalism
if we didn't have sponsors.
So thank you Incogni for
sponsoring today's video.
Incogni is actually quite
relevant to today's video,
because Incogni is
super-interested in data privacy.
We live in a world
where there's an entire secretive industry
dedicated to collecting
information about you
and no, this isn't the NSA spying on you.
This is for-profit
corporations who spy on you
in any way they can, so they can sell that
to other companies who
can then market to you,
who can into your phone, who
can try to make you buy things.
I find this incredibly
frustrating and violating
that my personal information
is bought and sold
on an open market.
Luckily, we have rights
to make this not happen.
The problem is the process
of making it not happen
is very complicated and
this gets me to Incogni.
Incogni is a service
that does this for you.
You sign up for Incogni and
you give them permission
to go out into the world on your behalf
and take you off as
many lists as they can.
The first thing they do,
and this is very satisfying,
is they scan to see all of
the lists that you're on
and they show it to you on
this really nice dashboard
so you can see, oh my God,
I'm on dozens if not hundreds
of these marketing lists.
And then they start the process
of securing your privacy,
of getting your email and your
address and your phone number
off these lists.
It's a process and Incogni
will keep you updated
on the progress.
They even have a tally of all of the lists
that you've been removed from,
which is insanely satisfying
to keep an eye on.
Because of Incogni, I
learned that here in the U.S.
there's this other massive problem,
which are these people search sites
where you can search for
people and it will pull up
as much information as
the site has on you.
I don't like that.
Incogni sniffed this out for me
and is taking me off of these lists.
Thank you, Incogni, I'm
very grateful for it.
So there's a link in my description.
It's incogni.com/Johnny
Harris and you can go over
sign up for Incogni and
try it out for 30 days
and get a full refund if
you don't think it's useful,
totally risk-free.
I'm really grateful to Incogni
for sponsoring our
journalism in this video,
but I'm also grateful that they exist,
because I am so tired
of my inbox and my phone
and my mailbox being full of garbage.
Okay, with that we're
jumping back into the video
about the government version
of collecting your data.
(videotape clicks)
We laid the first copper cable
across the Atlantic Ocean in 1858.
It connected Ireland to Canada.
They sent the first
telegram across this wire
and it took 18 hours to arrive,
which was like light-speed back then.
The cable broke three weeks
later, but even still,
it was a huge success,
a revolution for a world
whose progress hinged on
being more and more connected.
- [Narrator] Through a single cable,
only an inch and a quarter thick,
which lies on the ocean bed.
- [Johnny] The planet would be linked up
by many more of these cables
draped along the ocean floor,
allowing us to call
people across the world
and eventually allowing
us to access information
through webpages hosted
on servers far, far away.
- An online network called internet.
- Today, there are 1.4 million
kilometers worth of cables
linking us all up and they
transfer a ton of data,
like the fastest cables can transfer
224 terabytes per second,
and the amount of data being
sent around the world doubles
every two to three years.
Unsurprisingly, there's a whole industry
dedicated to just laying down these cables
and then monitoring
them and repairing them
when they break.
Sometimes they get broken by
fishing trawlers or anchors
or natural disasters.
Sometimes they even get broken by sharks,
though that's pretty rare,
but sometimes these cables
are broken on purpose.
There's this island right
off the coast of China,
but it technically belongs to Taiwan,
the country that China has
vowed to eventually absorb
into their own.
Needless to say, there's
a lot of tension here
and in the last five years,
the cables of this little island
have accidentally been broken 27 times,
which is a lot for cables.
China denies that they had any
part in these 27 accidents.
They say it's just an unfortunate fishing
or anchor incident, but I'm suspicious.
- [Reporter 3] Officials fear
that Matsu is just a warning
and that internet connections
to the whole of Taiwan
could be under threat.
- Sometimes it's unclear
who attacks these cables.
Like a few years ago
when somebody ripped out
a two and a half mile piece of this cable
that connects Norway to
the island of Svalbard.
Other times it's very clear
who's cutting the cables.
Like when the United States
was at war with Saddam Hussein
in the nineties and
they cut Saddam's cable
so that he couldn't communicate.
I mean, cutting the communication
cables of your enemy
is an old strategy.
They were doing that way back
in the American Civil War,
but the more interesting approach
to me isn't just sabotage.
There's another way
that you can use cables
to your advantage if you are a great power
trying to control things.
(electronic music)
If you have access to submarine cables,
which governments and militaries do,
you can scrape through the
insulation of this cable.
You can splice in another cable
and you can duplicate the signal
and hear everything your enemy is saying.
(people speaking in foreign language)
The British Navy did this
to a German submarine cable
out here in the middle of the
Atlantic, during World War I.
The Germans suspected that
they were being listened to,
so they sent all their
communication as complex codes,
but the British had
very smart code breakers
and they were able to decrypt all of this
and discover a lot of Germany's secrets,
and they discovered this
secret plan that Germany had
to ally with Mexico and
invade the United States.
This is one reason why the
U.S. ended up joining the war,
and it all happened because
of submarine cable tapping.
(uptempo beat music)
World War II took cable
tapping to a whole new level.
A more connected world
meant more opportunities
for vital military
information to leak out.
So the U.S. created a new agency
where they would tap in and monitor
hundreds of thousands of civilian
telegrams and phone calls
flowing through both the mail,
but also through these submarine cables.
I mean, think about it,
it was a scary time.
It was global war, it
was mass destruction,
so mass surveillance on
your people felt necessary
in the name of national security.
- [Reporter 4] Even the insides
of envelopes are scrutinized
for hidden writing by these sensors.
- This agency was shut
down after World War II,
but the seeds of mass
surveillance were now planted.
(techno music)
A few years later,
President Harry Truman creates
a new secret department,
the National Security Agency or NSA.
Their job was to secretly
collect and analyze communication
happening in the country,
communication that was not meant for them,
spying on communication of all kinds,
all in the name of national security.
By the time the United
States and the Soviet Union
are locked in a Cold War, spying
becomes even more valuable,
even more of a priority
for these governments,
and once again, underwater
cables become a target.
The Americans built this
entire spy submarine,
which had a secret space set
aside for intelligence officers
and a giant computer.
They called this space the bat cave.
Of course, they did, a
bunch of military dudes
on a submarine and they've
got their secret computers,
like, "We're in the bat cave."
I can totally see it.
This submarine called the USS Halibut
had a little mini-submarine-looking thing
that was actually not a mini-submarine,
but rather a pressurized
chamber full of special gas
that divers would just
sit in there and breathe.
It was pressurized to
feel like the deep ocean
so that these divers could
go out into the ocean
and be 400 feet under the surface
and their bodies were
ready for the pressure.
They used this to secretly
navigate to underwater cables.
The one we know about happened
over here right off the coast
of Eastern Russia.
The divers would leave their
pressurized gas chamber.
They would navigate this big, clunky
electric listening device onto the cable.
It's basically a giant 20' recorder
that would tap into the cable and record
everything passing through.
They somehow parsed through the
dozens of different signals,
specific phone calls
between Soviet officials,
but of course, this is the analog days,
so the storage on this
device would fill up,
so they had to go back with
their little bat cave submarine
every few months to replace the tape.
They did this for 10 years.
This was called Operation Ivy Bells,
and we talked about it a little
bit in the whole deep dive
we did on submarines.
But boy, it just never
ceases to blow my mind
how resource-intensive this operation was.
(water bubbles)
Anyway, through this
tapping on the Soviet cable,
the Americans learned just
how scared the Soviets were
by the buildup of nuclear weapons.
This helped them negotiate a slowdown
in the nuclear arms race
and even helped lead to
the end of the Cold War
according to one expert.
By the early nineties,
the Cold War was over.
- [President Clinton]
The change of centuries,
the dawning of a new millennium.
- But then came a world changing attack
into the ultraconnected internet age.
- This new law that I signed today
will allow surveillance
of all communications
used by terrorists, including emails,
the internet, and cell phones.
This government will enforce this law
with all the urgency of a nation at war.
It is now my honor to sign into law
the USA Patriot Act of 2001.
(audience applauds)
- In 2006, a leaked document revealed that
in a nondescript building in San Francisco
behind this random
yellow door labeled 641A,
the NSA had set up this
harmless-looking box
that tapped into the fiber optic cables
that traversed the
Pacific Ocean into Asia.
The phone company AT&T had
agreed to let them siphon off
the traffic that was moving
through their cables.
This seemed kind of nuts that
the U.S. was tapping a cable
where all of our
communication goes through,
but we had no idea what was coming.
In 2013, Edward Snowden,
an NSA contractor unleashed
one of the biggest leaks
in American history.
- This is the greatest hemorrhaging
of a legitimate American secrets
in the history of the Republic.
- And that is what we
have been looking through.
I mean, there's a lot more documents,
but we sifted through
and found the documents
that show us that it wasn't just one cable
in San Francisco being tapped.
The NSA was targeting every single cable
that touched the United States,
a huge amount of global traffic, email,
text messages, phone calls.
They had cooperation from
all these telecommunication
and tech companies to do this.
Microsoft, Yahoo, Google,
Facebook, PalTalk?
The hell is PalTalk?
Who knows, but the NSA
was tapping their cables.
YouTube, Skype, AOL,
and even Apple by 2012,
and their goal in all of this,
well, according to one of these slides,
the goal was to sniff it all,
know it all, collect it all,
process it all, exploit
it all, partner it all.
In other words, according
to another leaked slide,
to master the internet.
There's this one spreadsheet
in all of these leaked
documents that really said it,
here it is.
This is a list, a spreadsheet
of some of the cables
that the NSA had access to,
we literally know which ones.
I mean, we have the data
of all of these cables.
We could literally map all of these
from the southern cross cable
that connects California to Australia,
to the Apollo cable that
connects New York to France,
to the tiny cables that
connect Puerto Rico
to the British Virgin Islands.
All in all, by 2009,
the NSA had stuck a probe in
hundreds of submarine cables
all around the globe.
Oh, and they didn't do it alone.
The NSA partnered with
the OG masters of
Cable-tapping, the British.
- Since the 1940s, GCHQ and
its American equivalence
have had a relationship
that is unique in the world.
- Okay, so there's a
weird loophole thing here.
U.S. law allows the NSA to track anyone
outside of the United States,
but there are restrictions
when it comes to tracking
American citizens.
So to get around that,
they turn to their British
counterparts, the GCHQ.
So over the course of a couple
years in the early 2010s,
the NSA is paying 100 million
pounds in secret money
to gain access to all of this data,
this data that they call
a gold mine to exploit,
hundreds of thousands of names,
over 76,000 geocoordinates,
194 million messages collected per day.
And unlike the NSA,
the British could actually
spy on American targets,
but the point is they were
in it to collect it all.
- If information arrives in
the UK from the United States,
it's governed by our laws.
The system works as intended.
(suspenseful music)
- Okay, okay, yeah, it's a lot of data,
but what can you do with
600 million phone events
worth of data?
That's way too much for any
human to actually process,
and this is where it
gets kind of nuts to me.
We've got this slide, which by the way,
I know that we're dealing with
really top secret documents,
but they all have clip-art
and these templatized
Windows 95-looking
titles, freaking love it.
(jazzy drum music)
This slide, this complicated,
wonky, wonky slide
with this flow chart is
the answer to what they do
with all of this data, but
here's basically how it works.
So the NSA gets all of this data
of all of our communication,
either from cables or
from phone companies.
They funnel it through
this central processing
facility called Pinecone.
This is presumably
where they're processing
a lot of this data and
trying to find patterns.
The NSA says that their job is
to find suspected terrorists
or other people who want to
do harm to national security.
And to do this, they use
computers and algorithms
to make links between suspected terrorists
and their immediate network,
the people they call,
the people they talk to, where they are.
They say they only hold
on to those records
and they throw out everything else.
We don't know if that's true,
but let's just assume it is.
And then once it's all
processed and sorted,
it goes into a little searchable
database called XKeyscore,
which is a very clunky name,
but hey, great graphic design once again.
This is basically like
a internal search engine
that catalogs all of the metadata
that has been assigned to
all of this call message
geolocation information
and makes it searchable.
So you could pull up a
person, a suspected terrorist,
and you could find everything
you need to know about
who they talk to, where they
are, what their emails say,
or in their words, anything
you wish to extract.
It's all searchable on
this convenient platform.
This allows them to do searches like
let's look for an Arabic font,
Google query coming out of
the tribal areas of Pakistan,
and boom, they're linked in.
It's all right here in
XKeyscore the database.
Because of the globally connected world,
the NSA now has access to this person.
They can see what
messages they're sending.
They can see where they are right now,
assuming they have their phone,
all searchable in this
convenient database,
accessible to agencies
from other countries
and all over the world.
The whole assumption here is that in order
to find your target, the
terrorist, the spy, whatever,
you need to access all of the information,
this turns metadata into a
weapon of modern warfare.
- We kill people based on metadata,
but that's not what we
do with this metadata.
(suspenseful music)
- This revelation, all of these documents,
this whole Snowden drama was a big deal
for a lot of reasons.
One of the things it did
is it made the location of
cables really important.
Most of the cables were going
through the United States,
but after this leak,
countries started to look
for alternative routes
that bypassed the United States,
like this one that connects
Brazil to South Africa
and then goes on to Asia.
So over the last decade since these leaks,
the U.S. has become less
and less the epicenter
of cable connection, and you guessed it,
there's another player in town
who wants access to cables, China.
(suspenseful music)
China is rapidly building out
their worldwide network of cables,
and they're doing this through
Chinese state-owned companies like Huawei.
And this is adding yet another front
in this emerging Cold War
tension between great powers
that want to lead the global system.
It turns out that controlling
and spying on cables
is a requirement for global
leadership in 2023, who knew?
But unlike the U.S. who
purports to protect privacy
and civil liberties, but
secretly violates them,
China doesn't even pretend.
China has built a society
off of mass surveillance
and control of information.
Like here's actual footage of
how China tracks the movement
of its population through
visual recognition,
through cataloging every face, every car.
Information is power in this day and age,
and just a couple years ago,
the U.S. formed a new special
unit with intelligence
and regulation officials.
It's a group called Team Telecom,
and their job is to assess any
new projects, any new cables,
and make sure that they aren't going to
threaten or weaken U.S. interests.
For example, there was this one cable
that was supposed to
connect LA to Hong Kong.
It was being built by Google and Facebook,
and they were into the project,
hundreds of millions of
dollars into the project,
and this Team Telecoms
shut it down, too risky.
We can't have our fiber optic cables
going too close to China
less they spy on us.
This is making the map look really weird.
You used to only have to have
one major set of cables
connecting countries,
but now you're starting to see duplicates.
The Chinese lines and the American lines,
each building out their own network,
not connecting to each other.
It's like the perfect
symbol of the tension
that is rising between
these two superpowers.
The bifurcated world
that we're moving into.
China is connecting these
small remote islands
laying down cables.
And these islanders are
happy to have fast internet,
even if it comes from China
and is probably being tapped.
The continent of Africa,
the U.S. and China are both
laying down competing lines.
The country's caught in the middle of this
understand what's going on.
Two, aspiring hegemons vying for power,
each involved in spying
and sucking up information
in their own way,
but I guess it's worth it,
because it means faster internet,
it means connection to the world.
Russia is even trying to get in on this
with their aptly named
Polar Express cable.
And even though the old
school tapping into cables
in the middle of the ocean
to spy on your neighbor
is kind of outdated now,
there's some evidence that
Russia might be still doing this.
They've got this one
ship called the Yantar.
It's a surface ship that
is generally understood
to be a spy vessel,
and it's been spotted on the surface above
where we know submarine
cables are near Ireland
or near Syria.
Some think that they're
just tapping into them
like the old days,
maybe using one of these mini-submarines.
But even if they're not tapping into them,
they're very presence above
the cable is kind of a threat.
They could cut this cable at any moment.
The U.S. who is very good at submarines
has its own spy vessels,
the most secretive one
being the USS Jimmy Carter,
and we have no idea what it's up to.
Security experts speculate
that it's probably tapping
into cables for some reason,
somewhere at the bottom of the ocean.
But a lot of people in
the industry are like,
"No, that's so old days, why bother?"
It's so much easier to
just tap into them on land.
You get way more data
and you don't have to
go to the bottom of the ocean.
Meanwhile, the private companies
in charge of these cables
have started to up their own defenses.
They're taking all
these extra precautions,
including sending out
these submarine drones
that just spend their time
tracing along the bottom of the ocean,
babysitting these cables and making sure
that there's no damage
or tampering going on.
So I feel like I'm
gonna say what I've said
a bunch on the channel lately,
which is we are entering a
new chapter in geopolitics.
A globalized world is hyperconnected,
but suddenly and unexpectedly,
we're seeing a new set of divisions,
countries not trusting each other anymore.
Nations wanting to create
their own separate systems,
both economically, militarily,
but also with the
infrastructure of the internet.
A chapter where countries now
are more skeptical than ever,
especially great powers,
great powers that are building
their own infrastructure
so that they can communicate
and control information,
not trusting the other half of the world
to handle their data.
We see Navies with secret
ships that cost close to
a $1 billion a piece,
and then we see everyone
else caught in the middle.
And in the end, most of
us just want fast internet
connection with friends around the world
and a feeling that we're safe.
(suspenseful music)
All right, thanks for
watching today's video.
Just a little nugget here.
We did this video,
because we did the deep dive on submarines
a few months ago.
I don't know if anyone saw that,
but it was in that reporting
that we came across
the spying element of all of this.
And I remember I asked all of you,
do you want me to do this video?
And you all said, yes.
I got like so many comments
that were like, "Yes."
And so, we did it.
And that is one thing I love about YouTube
and being an independent
journalist on YouTube
is that I get to just ask you,
I'm talking to you and be like,
"Hey, do you want this?"
And you're like, "Yes."
And I go, "Okay," and I make it.
And there's no corporate
middleman who decides
what we make.
We make what you guys wanna see.
So as always, you can pitch us ideas
and we will hear them.
For those who want to support
more fully in our kind of
more intimate community,
we have a Patreon called the Newsroom.
The Newsroom is a place
where you can support
what we do here, but you also
get in on a few benefits,
including an extra behind
the scenes video every month
where you get to see all of
the people and the processes
and the shenanigans that
happen here in the studio.
We have a big team and
you get to meet them,
if you are a member of the newsroom.
You get access to my scripts,
you get access to Tom Fox music.
But really you get access
to the warm fuzzy feeling
that you're supporting a YouTube channel
that is trying to make rigorous journalism
in a time where facts and
truth are kind of eroding.
So if that floats your boat,
we would love your support.
We also have luts and presets,
which are like the thing
we use to color our videos
and our photos.
You could buy those and they
help support the channel.
We have a poster that I designed.
I'm super into map projections,
all the different ways
you can show a map shape,
and I made a beautiful poster that has it.
If you have that poster,
I think a lot of you have
purchased that poster,
we actually sold out and
we're reprinting a new batch,
so they should be in there.
Don't quote me on that because
they could be sold out again.
But anyway, if you have that
poster, tag me or something,
I wanna see what it looks
like out in the wild.
I looked at it on a screen for months
and now I have some here,
but I don't know what it
looks like out in the wild,
so share it with me.
I think that's it.
Anyway, that's all I've got.
Thank you all for being here,
and I'll see you in the
next video, bye-bye.
- [Narrator] Although the
calls through the cable
will be from many
nations, in many tongues,
the cable itself speaks
a single language to all
that is the language of
friendship and cooperation
between the men and women of
France, West Germany, England,
and the United States
who conceived and brought to completion
the cable to the continent.